I have constructed you in my
[Music]
brain when one says the word afterlife I
think most people immediately assume
it's a religious concept right and and
the first sort of question here is
actually could it be part of a
scientific account and what could that
look like and I'd like to invite you all
particularly uni because I'm curious I
should also say disclaimer I'm a
scientist too and I'm a biologist as
well so I I have I have a sort of
perspective on this thing as well but
I'd really love to see what we all think
could actually happen in this like how
can an afterlife exist scientifically
speaking and what what might that look
like like what is an afterlife really in
that secular view um I mean I think the
first thing to realize about science is
that there is no monolithic view of
Science and we don't know uh you started
out saying we don't know what
Consciousness is uh and that's true I
think we have ideas what it is but
nobody can agree no two people working
on Consciousness will agree about what
it is anyway so to say we have a clue is
wrong but to say that there's an
agreed um solution to it if you like is
is is wrong now uh I suppose if if there
is from my personally I see it as tied
to organic matter as tied to the the the
to cells and to to animals but if if it
were not um then I suppose the the idea
of pan psychism that ious is linked in
some way to a property of matter that we
know little about and there's plenty we
don't know about matter still so it's
it's easy to put two Mysteries together
and then think that we've solved
something but I know a lot of people and
perhaps some people in this room um
would would would see Consciousness not
as a property of a body but something
which is linked then with the wider
Universe with fields of some description
to my mind um electromagnetic fields are
an extremely important part of
Consciousness there's been very little
uh explored so far I think that the 21st
century biology will be a lot of it
about the biology of fields I would see
those fields as not necessarily going
very far beyond the limits of the
boundary and I personally don't see
those fields as linking with the
universe but some very good scientists
and I noticed Rupert sheldrake is here
and I've probably not captured anything
like his view on this but it perhaps it
would be something closer to that I do
not think that we have um a scientific
answer to that question I have a bias
other people have different biases and
we don't know the answer but it's not
impossible I mean I have to ask you all
CU obviously you've all touched upon the
Consciousness thing can I just clarify
when we talk about an afterlife are we
literally like is that an afterlife for
the Consciousness or is that an
afterlife for another part of ourselves
like is is it specifically about the our
Consciousness as we recognize it is that
is that a consensus or is that even Up
For
Debate uh well there are all sorts of
language issues and uh but what I think
what I think what I think is part of
what's Happening Here is that we think
that we've kind of dumped the the
religious
framework um uh that there's something
inside us that's going to continue
beyond that but I I think that carries
on and I think that carries on in all
sorts of ways so we have that kind of um
the the thing we set up this debate by
saying like we I can't remember the
phrase but you know kind of risible
religious ideas and uh the model for
that might be something like uh there's
this Immortal thing in us that will
Outlast this Mortal thing which is our
body um and um I think that's is kind of
rolling forward in the in the
Consciousness debate I use the word
Consciousness because it's kind of I
think it's more accessible Soul has its
own connotations right um uh but uh for
me uh I think um and I speak as as a
Christian uh what I read in my own
tradition is that the body is very
important so I'm unwilling to as it were
make that move I think it I don't think
it's I don't think it's a true U well I
don't think it's a fair representation
of the center of my own tradition I
think it's a kind of bastardization of
it uh that there's this Immortal thing
in us which is spinning out in one
direction or the other um so it like
what Nick's saying about the the
importance of the body and it and
whatever it is our consciousness I think
Consciousness probably gets to that idea
better than Soul our so we could we with
with the language of Soul we're trapped
in that absolute distinction between the
Flesh and this thing inside
us so if you ask a clinical scientist
what's the difference between religion
and spirituality we would use a twin
study using a twin study twins raised
together twins raised apart factoring
out their commonality as a function of
genes and environment we can determine
the extent to which any human trait is
inborn or environmentally formed
religion is a gift of our parents and
grandparents our community religion is
100% environmentally transmitted we
might choose a religion and immerse
ourselves spirituality is innate every
single one of us is born with an innate
seat of spiritual awareness how much so
by the time we're adults 30% innate it
is our Birthright and yet 2/3
environment mentally formed for many the
2/3 is the rich Embrace of a religious
tradition for others it is through ART
and poetry but every one of us is born a
spiritual being now let's take that down
one more level to MRI studies what is
the inheritance that is ours that is
innate our Birthright there is a neurod
docking station an innate seat of
transcendent awareness with which we are
all endowed in a culture that has
silenced multiple forms of knowing
multiple organic epistemologies we don't
hear much in K12 or in the boardroom
about the Deep neuros seat of
transcendent perception but you are not
an innately spiritual being due to your
belief but rather due to your ability to
perceive and know this is a form of
human perception at the inner table we
have a
logician we have of course a skeptic
who's most welcome we have an empiricist
a Mystic an intuitive and when we can
bring all know into tandem we see in our
MRI studies interconnections milina the
tracks highways between forms of knowing
for a more Innovative situationally
aware creative brain this is a room full
of artists and writers you have a highly
interconnected brain I might even
venture to Guess that the Muse or some
form of transcendent knowing may have
informed one of your Creations if you
ask
scientists if you ask a scientist 70% of
scientists who have made a meaning ful
contribution in their field report that
while the roll out of science perfectly
good lens was quite logically driven the
inspiration the question through which
they broke
ground was a proverbial apple on the
head from here it was a form of
transcendent experience dream mystical
experience synchronicity we're more we
are knowers in multiple forms and when
we own all forms of knowing we are ready
to move forward Ward you will not have
the problems we have now New Generation
you won't need to solve them they won't
happen in the first place I mean yeah I
mean feel free to jump in if if you have
um I mean I again I completely agree you
know science to me is very creative
Endeavor far more so perhaps than most
non-scientists would assume and also
than society would give it credit for
and to me you know a lot of a lot of my
day is trying to imagine how things
might be and occasionally something pops
into my mind and I don't know where it
comes from and this is what you're
calling Transcendence I'm putting it
very badly but so I'm not disputing at
all that these things exist and are real
and feel very real but this world around
us
all all you guys out there uh you're not
out there you're in here I have
constructed you in my brain there is no
you know any tree that I see over there
everything everything I see in the world
around me you're not physically in my
head what's in my head is a bunch of
neurons a bunch of electrical wiring and
so on and and it's put together in a way
that we can barely understand and it
constructs a world and we interact with
that world during early development we
walk into trees we hurt ourselves we we
we figure out that that is not moving
it's bigger than me and it hurts um and
and and so we we piece together the
world and if you keep someone in a I
mean apparently this kind of thing
happens keeps someone in a dark room
until they're six or something they
never can see properly because they you
know the the the neuron the synaptic
Connections in the mind is too late for
them that plasticity of forming the
links to understand what you're seeing
it's too late so if the mind and clearly
it is because it is for absolutely
everyone here capable of constructing
this astonishing world what a beautiful
part of the world that we're in you know
we we are able to construct all of this
in our heads and we can agree about
what's out there um so what happens when
some of this goes wrong I know for a
fact that my mind is capable of
constructing an amazing world it doesn't
surprise me very much that it's also
capable of constructing all kinds of
Horrors all kinds
of forms of me you know mental
derangement in one way or another and it
will it happen to me I don't doubt it
so I don't see a need again to believe
that it's coming from somewhere else I
see my own mind as capable of doing
things that I cannot understand but it
doesn't mean to say it's coming from
over there it means it's coming from in
here to my mind to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit I a.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas